toutes les enquêtes se font sur
l'escroquerie parce qu'aujourd'hui le
code pénal français ne reconnaît plus la
rue l'action de sorcellerie n'existe
plus s'amenant existe peuvent donc on
travaille sur l'argent nicolas pernikoff
qu'on n'a pas entendu où elle nous a pas
convaincus en fait moi elle m'a pas
convaincu du tout d'abord elle parle
bien elle est extrêmement hétérogène
mais là où je suis quand même très
surpris mais je fais ici et si on la tue
c'est sur les montants je n'arrive pas à
croire qu'elle a pu donner un million de
moi c'est incroyable sorcière ben milad
web
elle était coiffeur donc elle à la
valeur non mais avant elle avait elle
nous l'a expliqué 500000 aux dépens de
nom mais elle est là elle a une vraie
valeur de l'argent au départ mais c'est
incroyablement on peut pendant des
années des années donné un million trois
cent mille euros quand vous voyez la
complexité à faire ne serait ce que des
virements de cinq ou dix mille euros
la banque vous bloque pour essayer de me
suivre pourquoi vous faites des
virements pourquoi vous faites des
chèques en plus elle l'aurait fait sur
sa holding
vous savez bien qu'on est quand même en
plein dans l'abus de biens sociaux je
crois elle l'a fait c'est incroyable moi
ce que j'aimerais bien voir un c'est la
preuve des montants ont été versés à
cette série ça me paraît incroyable bio
c'était un investissement pour elle
puisque la voyante lui disait tu va
cartonner dans les marseillais tu vas
gagner beaucoup d'argent on sait
aujourd'hui que les influenceurs est
tant mieux pour eux ils gagnent
énormément d'argent donc elle s'est dit
si je dépense vingt ou trente mille
euros par mois dans cette voyante mais
qu'elles m'ont fait gagner je sais pas
50 60 70 elle continuer de dépenser
maintenant six mois et demi tout ça en
place et elle calcule exactement les
moqueries millions d'euros à des
montants qu'elles puissent payer mais
qu'elle puisse encore gagné d'argent
derrière mais c'est vrai que c'est
démonter cerisaie d un champ sans dire
le salaire de carla les principaux
influenceurs avec les placements de
produits
le salaire démarre à cent vingt mille
euros et va jusqu'à 400 mille euros
alors essai sur la société donc cédé
montant énorme énorme donc voilà donc ça
fait à peu près 9 à beaupréau en moyenne
entre 50000 et 204 280000 humains par
moi aussi je vous dis ce sont des vrais
montant gilles verdez oui je les connais
également ça c'est une vraie info et
c'est vrai que gilles ne dis pas de
bêtises ce sont ces montants là c'est
entre 120 milles et 400000 euros en
factures par mois pour des très gros
d'un brillant soeur voilà c'est à laval
jusqu'à 400 mille euros je vous le
confirme et que d'une aide pour ceux qui
sont à dubaï escapade impôts adorent
exactement
le dr tout l'argent des sociétés c'est
d'une aide dans la poche ou vous gagnez
deux à trois fois plus instantanément là
bas c'est énorme
rexie m'intéresse c'est comment tu
deviens influenceurs et ben déjà
déjà faut savoir se servir des réseaux
sociaux déjà vous allez envoyer des
cartes postales pour une question oui
vous est très suivie le soir des réseaux
ces millions sur twitter à peu près oui
et à plus d'un million sur serein sur un
soir histoire de a proposé de l'argent
pour faire des placements honnêtement
alors oui ah voilà oui oui et
aujourd'hui déjà fait un nom jamais
cette commande le faire que vous n'avez
pas besoin en même temps oui puisque
c'est que ces mots à l'oreille
non mais pas d'une armée gens là mais
voilà on va dire la vérité pour 1 pour 1
million de followers sur un stade
on est plutôt autour de 10 à 15000 euros
pour un emplacement pour dépend du taux
d'engagement d'accord mais voilà dans
les séries benjamin me suis jamais fait
monsieur voilà jeu